luther king junior day I don't think I
could say anything that would live up to
his legacy in any way but he was he was
courageous and uncompromising and I
think above all he believed in justice
and I believe we should all strive for
that and if you haven't read his words
or watch him speak do yourself a favor
and do that today they're as powerful as
they ever were tributes have been all
over social media like this tweet
honouring King and his quote incredible
career fighting for civil rights using
an excerpt from King's letter from a
Birmingham jail which reads injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere that's a wonderful quote I
wonder who tweeted that oh it was the
FBI the FBI same FBI you spent your
spine to hunt him in blackmailing MLK
because our director and constipated
bullfrog in a miniskirt J Edgar Hoover
called dr. King quote the most notorious
liar in the country the only thing that
would be crazier of Mel Gibson tweeted
Happy Hanukkah sugar tits
and ladder this MLK tweet from the FBI
what's another surprise reversal tweet
the FBI might send out John Hodgman hey
Anthony Weiner cool dong dude
[Applause]
dude cool Doug just cool down dude
Eugene Mirman
hey Vladimir Putin where do you want us
to drop off your laundry all right boys
Josie long just hey Stanley Kubrick you
did such a great job faking the moon
landings and then hashtag jet fuel can't
melt steel beams
[Applause]